You want to start by telling you
something about yourself that you may have
forgotten. Is that okay?
All right. So here it is.
Ready?
You are wonderful.
And now we'd like you to amplify that
by pointing to the person next to you.
Make eye contact point to them with
your finger. This finger pointing. Okay.
And we're gonna all do it at the same
time. All right, pick the partner,
look at them and I point and let's go.
You are wonderful.
And now point to yourself and say hi am
wonderful and now point to all of us and
say we are wonderful.
And that's the truth.
Say it.
That's the truth.
And we do this exercise. It's
a great warmup exercise, right?
But it's also the truth that
when all of us were little,
we lived in a technicolor world and life
was wonderful and we had the capacity
for amazement, but something happened
and we lost that. And how I learn,
I believe that that what was
lost was the experience. So full,
a liveliness and the, that's what
we're looking for. We wanted again.
So our view is that we
live in an interconnecting,
interactive universe in which
everything there is in the universe has
connecting.
And that's the core word that we use.
And we've been studying for decades now.
How come people don't feel
connected and connecting?
And what we discovered is there's a
fundamental thing that happens that all
human beings,
we've picked us up in the,
in the clinic and we also find it's true
in all the ecosystems we've worked at.
There is an objection to difference.
And the objection to difference
has something to do with
the fact that we're not
connecting.
So there's a paradox there and you
can't get to connecting by objecting to
difference so that you have
to do something else. So
objecting to difference,
um, producers or polarization and when,
what we would like to do is produce,
connecting. And Helen's
going to talk about, uh,
this in just a moment, but our
primary discovery was about talking.
We thought it was about helping people
solve problems. What we discovered,
it's about talking and the talking is
the most dangerous thing most people do
listening.
It's the scariest thing.
And the most infrequent because if you're
listening, you may hear something that,
uh, dissipate your own view
of how the universe works.
But most people can't talk about their
difference or about their needs without
going into polarization.
So we are excited to share with others
the fact that there's a new relational
science and new technology that has
never existed in the world before.
Marriage therapy has been
very murky in past. Uh,
and people have long to get along,
but they just don't know how
something breaks down. But,
um,
in this new relational science,
we emphasize that conflict isn't
a bad thing in the relationship.
We phrase it conflict is
growth trying to happen.
If you hold the conflict right,
you'll both discover something new and
transformative about each other and the
relationship.
Um,
and the problem with conflict
is that people wait too long.
John Gottman,
anyone heard of him?
Top marriage researcher in the country.
A lot of you raised your hands.
He says if you have a pain in your chest,
the average time it takes to pick up
the phone and call nine one one is four
hours.
If you have a pain in your
relationship and your heart's breaking,
the average time it takes up to pick up
the phone and call the doctor is seven
years.
People wait too long and some of that
reason and then the problem's so big,
it's harder to deal with the,
um,
the reason people wait probably is they
don't know that there was something that
can really help.
And now we're so glad to share that fact.
It's so good now that we work with someone
who says we could end all divorce on
the planet.
And um,
his thought is that boyfriend a
couple applies for a marriage license.
Shouldn't it be like a driver's license?
I mean,
shouldn't you have to like read a manual
and take a test and maybe show a little
proficiency before you get your license
and make the most important decision of
your life? So, and also
the, it's so simple.
This stuff can be taught in grade school
now and is beginning to be taught in
grade school and ref.
If we're raised learning this,
um,
this technology of relationship,
we would really have a
transformed, you know, family,
workplace, place, world.
So, um, basically,
um, Harville and I were dating and, um,
uh, I was divorced. He was
divorced and I said, Harvel,
if you could wave a magic wand,
what would you like to do with your life?
And he said, ah, I just,
I'm so curious,
why do couples fight?
And he began to share some
of his thoughts. I said,
tell me what are your thoughts,
but are they,
as they came out after dating for awhile,
I proposed and he agreed to marry me.
And this book got written and
when it came out in the first,
um, two months when it
came out, I thought,
who's going to buy a book
by a man named horrible?
I was really worried about that.
But apparently Oprah read it.
And then she, they, a
studio called and said, um,
we liked him on the show.
So she took his show and submitted
it to the emic committee and that,
oh, that show one, Oprah, her
first Emmy. So she had him on,
um,
about 15 times and pretty soon
the book was in 60 languages.
And, uh, it's a system, a
therapy system called a Margo.
And there are 2,500 a Maga therapist
who've gotten training in 37 countries.
So we know this stuff
works. Uh, we just, um,
we're talking with some of the other
relationships scientist and we co,
cause we were all saying this stuff is
you shouldn't have to pay for therapy.
It's gotten so simple. So we, uh,
we'll tell you a little bit
later about the fact that, uh,
these therapists had tried to do
this in one city and we're doing, um,
we're disseminating this information
in Dallas and if it works in Dallas,
it's going to go global.
So it'll tell you about that in a minute.
But we're now going to ask,
we're going to show you the technology
of safe conversation and then we're gonna
ask you to sit next to someone
and do what we do and learn.
Learn this,
practice
Europe with the person with whom
you exchanged. Wonder. So, um,
when Helen and I were dating,
she mentioned that early
in our relationship we
discovered that we were both
very intense people,
positively and negatively.
And one day we're having a,
uh,
one of our negative intensities
in her living room and Helen said,
uh, stop this one of us talk
and the other one listen.
And so that was sort of
broke the cycle and we did.
And one of the other illicit.
And we found that it regulated
us in a way that was surprising.
And I was in the clinic at that time
and began to couples learn to talk in a
different way,
um,
and sort of as a result of that and began
to study talking and that most people
talk in monologues or parallel monologues.
I talked, I talked to you talk,
I talked to you and talk. We, we
don't talk, we don't interface.
And what we wanted to do is change.
That's a vertical way of talking wound
to change that vertical to a lateral.
And we developed this
process called a dialogue,
which we rebrand and Dallas
called safe conversation.
We want to show you briefly,
uh,
what the structure of that looks like and
to see that what we discovered is that
conversations that have a structure and
a process tend to produce safety and
connecting conversations that are
random and don't have a process tend to
sometimes produce safety and connecting
generally produce polarization in chaos.
So there's a simple,
some simple processes can
transform conversations and
we can get back a sense of
connecting, which we think is
so in indigenous to our nature,
that's what we really want.
So safe conversation is the foundational
tool and it's guests got a steers.
The structure I was talking about
fundamentally is to learn the practice of
mirroring. And let me see
if I got it. As you can see,
we put in some sentence stems.
Let me see if I got what you said.
Then the second thing that's important
is accuracy, accuracy, check. Uh,
in research on listening,
there's a seven,
a 13% accuracy rate than
what most people here,
87% distortion rate.
So it's really important that you
say to somebody who's talking to you.
Let me mirror that back. Let me see if
I got that. Did I get it? And then, uh,
the other thing that most people don't
do is say, is there more about that?
They usually say, well, you'd
done and now it's my turn to talk.
Then we go through validation,
which is to see the sense that they're
making and to empathy to reflect back the
feelings. Now that's a
structured conversation. You
can do it with just a mirror.
Wayne, you can do validation or
empathy. Helen and I want to, uh,
we're going to do a,
like a five minute demo of that and
then we're going to ask you to do that.
One of the things that we discovered in
great conversations is nuance that it
has very little to do with what
is big but has to do with small.
And one of those is icontact.
Um,
many people walk around with hard eyeballs
and their pupils are small and that's
what we call the glare. And you remember,
have you seen glares around? Uh,
you can look at somebody's face and you,
cause that person has clothes,
pupils are small.
You can read that.
So what we help people do is identify
the hardness of the and the smallness of
the pupil hardness of the eyes
and switch it to the gaze.
This is the kind of face you want to look
at while you're talking where there's
receptivity,
where the pupils are large and you
know that what you're saying is being
received. And so we also help
people regulate the flow.
That is somebody who's talking to you and
you stop listening and you know you're
being flooded to how to sing. He's
just raise your hands. Say God,
can you hold on a minute, let me
mirror back what I'm hearing so far.
Just regulate your own input instead
of getting over flooded and saying,
I can't listen to anymore,
are reacting to it.
So here's what the bureau
of an appreciation and
looks like as a conversation
and this is what Helen,
I are going to do. So
now we are,
we've decided that we're guests going to
do a one way because of the constraints
on time here. And the one way, um,
we'll be that Helen is going to send
me some information and I'm going to
respond on the receiver side. She'll
be the sender and I'm going to be, uh,
the receiver
and we're teaching the
technology, uh, that, uh,
my expressing an appreciation. But
uh, this is the technology can you,
you can use when you have a frustration
with someone yup. And you can, uh,
then it will make any
conversation go better. So, um,
yeah. And one other thing is we think
of it as a vehicle, like a truck.
It's like thinking of it as a drug.
And this is the way the truck works.
You can put any cargo on the trunk
and it will go to any market.
If the truck doesn't work,
you can't get the car go to market.
So this is the truck
and you've got the sentence
stems in your seat.
So you'll be using this
patient can do it with darn,
or if you want to turn in
your ma in your handout,
you can see a mirroring and appreciation
is the title of the extra credit that's
up on the slide. So dope. So horrible.
Is this a good time when I could give you
an appreciation? Yes. Now's a good time.
Thank you. Well, um,
when we practice this
in the taxi coming over,
w what popped out in my mind was your tie.
I just loved that you've
ordered that tie this morning.
I haven't seen it for years.
And um,
I just really thought that
was a cool tie to wear.
So if I'm getting this,
the appreciation you have is the
tie I'm wearing that you, uh,
you looked at it and you
hadn't seen it in years and uh,
and you're really appreciating the time.
Did I get that? Yes, I've got that.
So is there more about it?
Um, well that, that tie just in the taxi,
it just made me feel exuberant
and joyful for Nice thought.
So the tie made you feel exuberant and
joyful? Am I getting that? Yeah, yeah.
So is there more about that,
about the failing? Um, uh,
well I that point I feel that way.
It did remind me of my uncle
Jimmy because uncle chimney,
my favorite uncle would always wear
shirts that were real lively and sort of
head little critters from the
farm on them. He would, he'd be,
he lives in Idabel,
Oklahoma and it was like fun
trees and flowers and um,
so it sort of warmed my heart.
Sing that.
So when you had that feeling, it
reminded you of uncle Jimmy on the farm.
You've got all these critters and who
was fun? Uh, did we read that around?
So you were a manager of a very warm
experience and very pleasant experience.
So by getting that, they get it. They get
all of that. So is there more about that?
Well, yeah, and uncle Jimmy would
play with us. They may go visit. Okay.
But my father,
it was a real contrast and my father who
always wore the business suit and never
played with me or any of the kids.
So it reminded you that,
um, of your father,
his son is very different. He didn't
play with Dewey wore business suits,
more severe clothing and didn't play.
And you don't have those warm memories
with him. Am I, am I getting that right?
So is there more about that?
So let me see if I've got all of it.
Um,
if I could summarize it.
You want to give me an appreciation
and the appreciation is of my tie,
which you notice this morning
and when you saw my Thai,
you had a strong feeling of exuberance
and joy and when you had that feeling it
triggered a memory of your uncle Jimmy,
uh,
with who had colorful clothes and had
all these animals and looked on her farm
and you know,
really warm memories of him.
And you don't have those
memories of your father who was,
didn't play in which ward more severe
clothing. Did I get all of that? Yes.
Well thank you for sharing that. Thank
you for listening. They're welcome.
And we also make some sort of
physical contact and couples hug
usually for a minute. If
you're not a couple, we have
some sort of physical contact because
the neurochemistry and neurochemical is
released. When you make physical
contact with somebody you're talking to,
it could be either cortisol or endorphins,
but you want to be sure it's correct
that it's endorphins instead of cortisol.
So you'll notice that it starts with an
appointment. Does now good time to talk.
That's what the center does.
People's boundaries.
And just because someone's ready to talk
doesn't mean you're ready to listen.
And when you don't cross a boundary,
you're being, you ask if you can,
uh Oh,
somebody can open themselves,
then you regulate and create more safety,
then you make eye contact.
And eye contact is a really
very important thing to do.
When you start a conversation, then you
start sending the message, mirroring it,
and then summarizing it.
So what we'd like to do now is ask you
if we could turn on a little light so we,
you all can see each
other and we can see you.
If you would practice this and pick
a person that's sitting next to you,
um, and a desk, just do it
quickly. The two and then two,
and to all of you all are already
paired over there. There's two,
four,
six people here to four is that two,
six.
And maybe you could pair with the one on
the end there and then to four and you
pair with the first one on the end over
there. And uh, are you all want to be,
why don't y'all figure it
out? You're smart. You're it,
you're a Google pair up with
somebody awkward. It's like,
could you learn to ski slope or
a little bit, but then if you,
it's a very powerful tool to use
this and all your relationships.
So pretty soon you can go down the double
black diamonds swishing and then if
you can, uh, as going to be hard, I
think in turn the chairs all the way.
Usually we have people
face to face to face,
but turn as much toward the person
you're working with as possible.
Also decide who's going to start first.
And we want this years to go both ways
and we're going to get you started.
Okay? If you don't have a partner, okay,
here's someone without a partner.
Okay.
Is there any other person in the
room without a partner? Yeah. Okay.
So you're going to partner with you.
All right.
So now, now we're all
part good. So we'd like,
I like to get you
started at the same time.
So turn and look at the person
and you all decide quickly, uh,
who's gonna go first?
And I'll,
let me just make that easier by saying
the one on the left goes first and you
usually, it's a different thing. If
you're a couple's, it'd be who does,
who talks a lease. And they go first
and who talks the most? They go second.
Decide who's gonna go first
and then make eye contact.
So he got got, who's going first? Okay,
I'm sorry, I don't make eye contact.
Make the appointment is now a good time.
So say to that birth is now a good time
to share and appreciation with you?
And you'll be looking at this person
and you'll pick out something about that
person. You appreciate it. Now a good
time and you'll say, oh, of course.
Yes.
Then make eye contact. Just
pause, just make a pause
and then go into and follow the follow
either the screen or the thing in your
lap on mirroring out appreciation.
All right. Get started. Go.
And we're going to give you
five minutes each to do this.
Okay, great. Okay. And keep
going if you're finishing up,
but we're just going to have two or
three of you if you'd like to just share
what that was like. Yeah. Anything about
just your, what, what happened during
while I was doing this, not a question,
but a comment.
Any sensations that you had or thoughts?
Yeah, so even though, what's that?
Oh Gosh. Hello. Um, as you said, it
was a little awkward and structured,
but at the same time I did feel extremely
connected to my partner when we were
having the conversations.
Great.
Thank you.
So it felt a little awkward
because of all the structure,
but the result was you felt really
connected using that. Thank you.
Anyone else want it anymore?
Yeah,
we ended up going farther off script,
but it led very naturally into stories
about where we came from and and these
little prompts ended up becoming a
a whole very natural conversation.
Yes. So, um,
you went off script a
little and shared stories,
but then it became a real
wonderful conversation.
Great, thank you. Yeah.
Normally when I'm having a conversation
with someone when they're talking,
I'm not necessarily thinking I'm thinking
of my next response or then you go
along with it. But in this thing,
and this, in this scenario,
all I was thinking was how am I going
to repeat back what they said and make
sure I absolutely understood it.
I'm thinking Alex.
Okay,
Alex.
And then there's one more hand and that'll
be it for now because there's time at
the end.
But Alex,
thank you for being really vulnerable
that you noticed that you were going to
have to mirror,
but then when your partner was talking,
you were aware that instead of marrying,
you'd really like to also tell him what
you think or edited or like you were
ready to engage with your thoughts
instead of taking the time to mirror.
And so that, that was a real deliberate
thing you had to do. Did I get that?
Thank you. Identical observational.
Pardon me? Same observation. Same.
Same. Uh, so Harvard said statistic,
he read about listening
that we get 17% accuracy,
accuracy,
accuracy of listening.
We think we hear and that's why it's
really important to mirror and say,
is that what you said?
Because um,
we do this for CEOs of corporations all
the time that they don't know how to
mirror or here,
but the other people were saying too
and so interesting to see the,
Oh my God,
I got 13% or what usually is that?
The other thing we want to say
is that the structure is awkward,
but it moves into
interacting with your cortex.
And so that you actually integrate your
brain from feeling when you go into
memories, you go into feelings
and thoughts, feelings,
thoughts, feelings, thoughts.
So that when you engage in a structured
conversation that moves back and forth
between information,
that emotion,
you strengthened the neural pathways
in the brain toward non reactivity and
cohesion.
So it's an interesting structure.
So Helen's going to talk more about that.
So the other thing we said
in the taxi this morning,
we're going to look up the definition
of relationship because um,
cause I think most people think,
and so it would be more official that
the definition of a relationship is two
people and horrible.
And I say the definition of a relationship
is two people and the space between
them and the focus of the relationship
should not be on either person,
but on the space between
and how successful you are
in your relationships all
depend on how safe this space between is.
And so,
um, um, sorry.
So there you are. This is, this
is really the important thing.
Um, and so we, um,
prescribed for people call
a zero negativity process.
It's really hard not to end up negative
around people around you. Just, you know,
just to look in your eye
or the tone of your voice,
much less what you say is often making
someone next to you feeling uncomfortable.
Um, and we emphasized with the zero
negativity process, it's not what you say,
it's how you say it. You
can talk about anything, uh,
with Pr, you know, with people. But
if you make an appointment, you may I,
and yeah,
I'd like to share this is now a good time.
And then there's a way
to talk about anything,
but it does in a way that isn't received
so negatively because if it's received
negatively by that person,
they're not going to want to do it.
So this is a way to get you what you want.
Also taking the time to affirm,
uh, being positive energy
into the space between.
So we think that mental health is focused
on the physics of the within. And,
um,
I love being the number two to Harvel
the number one physicist who is really
mapping out the science of relationship
in the physics of the between.
So all of this horrible also
woke up one day and said to me,
the couple is the upstream prevention
that can prevent all the down river
cleanup.
If we clean up the relationship at home,
then the kids don't get teen pregnancy,
chemical dependency,
street gangs, and, and then
they do better in school.
And then there isn't the breakdown of
the economics in the families and in the
community. So if we can just bring
this technology really anywhere,
all of this as we're wanting to unleash
it, is going to help we believe,
create a more relational culture.
We have a culture that just,
I think you all are so rewarded.
And me too and horrible.
If we got the best grade in the class,
if we won,
if we'd got to the top of the ladder,
that's how we're rewarded.
Our parents just love us when we do
that. Uh, the job, our bosses love us.
They give us a reward if we're the best.
And we have a world that's
all about competition,
that that can lead to domination to winner
take all to all sorts of things that
really aren't healthy for the world,
the human family.
And so we think sharing this relational
technology is really going to help teach
something we all want, which
is collaboration, cooperation,
the creating of win-wins. So, um,
we're really sort of about
a relationship revolution.
Oh,
the thing that we're focusing on is to
discover the problem in working with
couples as conversation.
So we had to help them learn how to
talk and then when they learn to talk,
uh,
they did not have many problems.
In fact, the problems were because they
couldn't talk. Does that make sense?
It's kind of a paradox.
And so given that that worked,
we knew that then that a human problem,
not just a couple of problems.
And so we want to, uh, decided that
we would spend the rest of our lives,
uh, taking a very small thing called safe
conversation, which you just practice,
uh, in multiple forms and distribute
safe conversations globally.
And we started with Dallas and we are
working on a citywide project in Dallas.
We have probably impacted now about
5,000 families and on Google a youtube.
Uh, last year we did a global,
uh, but did a big project and,
and um,
I did a multimedia in about 40,000 people,
watched the workshop on Google,
15,000 at any time on Facebook.
And we had about a 20 million
numbers for our media footprint.
So started with Dallas.
But we now see it going globally.
And what we see ourselves doing is doing
something that has not been done much
in our culture. That culture is
focused on individual competency,
on being the best you can be,
own all and winning.
And we're shifting the focus
to relational competency,
which we think paradoxically again, that
when you're into relational competency,
you actually function better as an
individual because neurochemical things
happen,
muscular things happen and your immune
system works differently when you feel
safe in context and rather than a
feeling challenged and dangerous.
So here's basically what this does
and this is the first piece of it.
We don't have time to do validation.
And empathy,
but fundamentally we want to move
from having a safe conversation,
which is fine.
Anytime anybody wants to talk and needs
to talk for 215 or 20 minutes about a
topic,
but to take the things that make
that structured conversation were and
distributed into all conversations
so that we move from making,
having a safe conversation to
making all conversations safe.
Then what we do is regulate, uh, anxiety.
We create safety and we optimize then
the human family and re-experience our
true nature,
which we think is the felt experience
of connecting and the full of liveliness
that comes with that and the wonder of
full of likeness. So honoring boundaries,
very important.
Anytime we encourage,
anytime you talk to is now a good time
to talk about that instead of just
walking in and taking over
their cognitive space,
it's not a good time to talk about it.
Then the mirror says, well, let's see it.
They said, yes. Well
let me see if I got it.
The new mirror accurately,
you don't interpret change are in,
in any way modify the sin.
Accuracy check. Very important.
Did I get that? I get with just
that. And if you did then say, well,
is there more about it?
So to move to curiosity
rather than usually at that
point we replaced the other
person with ourselves. We say,
you know, uh, so did I get that?
Well let me, let me tell you what
I think. No, go to the next step,
take a pause and say,
is there more about that?
And what you'll find is that it's so
unusual for that question to be asked that
many people will say, well, no, uh,
but if you sit with that then took one,
just check in and see new things will
bubble up and then the really rich things
will start happening.
I think people put things into words
that before had just been feelings or
thoughts. And then how were they
getting through? Do a quick summary.
So it was if I got all that. So you
said, hey, and then you, yeah, it was,
you appreciated this and you felt about
that and that reminds you of something.
And what we found is that whether it's
a negative or positive interaction,
there's always a memory connected to it.
That somehow our past is
always present in our present.
And whether it's a pleasant
thing or an unpleasant thing,
there's a memory that that experience
gets attached to. And if you know that,
then your life makes sense.
If you don't know that,
then you wonder why the hell
are you behaving that way?
It's because something in the past
is intruding into the president.
So that's basically what we wanted to say.
And we now turn it over to you to see
what you want to say back to us in terms
of thoughts, expressions, questions,
and if you have any questions
we'll make up an answer.
Yeah.
And I think we have now,
how long? About 15 minutes.
Okay.
So this works for appreciations.
What if you have a complex,
is the conversation structure the
same? It's a, it's structured.
Oh. And the content becomes a, this
frustration I have with you is,
and then you have to mirror that back and
then there's, they're more about that.
And then, uh, check with the
feeling about the frustration.
I feel real like I want to kill you.
You know,
you're a terrible person and I
feel angry and hurt and so forth.
So you mirror back the feeling and
then, um, then you say, and you know,
at this frustration, all frustrations
are also rooted in memory.
And this reminds me of my father
who did extra, my mother who did.
Why there's still the person mirrors
that back and there's a more complicated
thing. If a behavior
actually needs to be changed,
there's a that that would
take a little longer to teach.
But there is a process of identifying
what new do you need from me that would
regulate that frustration for you.
So what we encourage people, Helen,
Helen is very good at this saying,
astro what you want.
Every frustration is a wish in disguise.
And most of us don't pay
attention to the wish.
We pay attention to the frustration.
Like you were late. You never do that.
You've always done that.
And if you ever hear or frustration and
just listen to it, you'll hear the wish.
I wish you were doing on time. I wish you
would call me, you know, before seven,
I wish there's a desire.
So we could say, Oh boy,
I've got this thing going on. I want
to really, I'm really frustrated.
What do I want?
And then extract from that and go bring
that to the person instead of what you
don't like. Then that creates more
safety, more cohesion and more connecting.
So and so,
but that's a long process.
It's just the dialogue that we
did can address a frustration,
but sometimes there is another more
structured conversation around,
uh, it's called a behavior
change request. Is there more?
Well, yeah, I guess that
was, that was the question.
Like it doesn't necessarily have to
be something someone's doing wrong.
Maybe you're picking like the color of
your wall, just one person wants. Right?
And One person wants blue.
So you ask someone to explain
their feelings for red and you say,
okay, well I understand your feelings
for red. Right? But that what,
so what happens when you do
the relational, something
like safe conversations.
If you're in your lower brain,
the reptilian brain. Do,
have you studied any brain
science? No. No, no. Okay.
Three parts of Reptilian rule.
We can even say there's
a reptilian brain and um,
the near Cortex and the reptilian
brain is fight or flight or freeze.
But the NEOCORTEX kick create,
win wins and just using,
um, you know, I really liked the bedroom
to be blue because I, that is the,
that's what I'll really sleep well in
and what I really want red because I want
to wake up and feel that.
And if you just go at it without
a structured conversation,
you're going to end up in your lower
brain and just saying the sentence stems,
uh, put you in the upper
brain, like in a mirror wing.
It puts you up here instead of your,
and you know,
the intense down here and you can
better solve a problem around purple.
Yes. That's got a little blue.
It's got a letter read. Yes.
Yeah. It'll be more easy to
find that kind of compromise.
And what,
what we discovered happens is if you
hear me and listened to me and can get,
my view is that I like
blue and you really get it.
So would it make sense that you're like
blue, I don't have to have blue anymore,
but if you say bluets sucks,
I have to tell blue. And I,
we learned this, uh, actually, uh,
there's a story about we didn't know when
we have six children, so one of them,
we were walking to school one morning
and, um, no, no, it was about bedtime.
I don't want to go to bed. I couldn't
go to bed. So we just mirror.
So you really don't want to go to bed.
You don't want to go back. Say it.
Say more about that.
I don't want to go bad because they're
always putting me to bed and just
mirrored everything and took him by his
hand and walked him down the hallway to
his bedroom and sat down and hugged
him and said, good night. He said,
thank you dad for listening
and went to sleep.
So I'm here with him and his
objection, uh, dissolved.
He just simply wanted to be heard.
And we find that's basically what's true.
Once we heard,
then we can collaborate and cooperate. If
we're not hurt, will polarize. Alright.
Thank you. And God made us
that way. I don't blame me.
Thanks for laughing at my jokes.
And you didn't like the guy when I
have to point them out everywhere.
Anything else we've got it
looks like 10 more minutes.
Yes.
So,
um,
it's easy to imagine that you guys have
this like really perfect relationship
because you're experts in
communication and most of us aren't.
I'm just curious if there's, we do save
that. Let me see. We do mirror that back.
What I hear you say is you expect that
we can talk about communication real
comfortably because we're real compatible
and we have a good relationship to,
we can put it out there. Did I get there?
Yeah. And I, and I'm very [inaudible],
I'm curious to know if there's still
issues these guys are still working on and
what does that look like? Right? So if
you have issues, what does it look like?
Well. Um, we actually were
condensing an an 18 hour workshop,
$850. If any of you want to
come to our workshop. No,
we'll competent to interview at Google
the justice route. We're not going to do
anyway.
And at that workshop,
Harvell has given me the permission to
tell the story that I'm about 20 years
ago. Yeah. Almost 20 years
ago, our marriage was so bad.
We both had so wanted the
book to get promoted and, and,
but we forgot to do it and we were,
it was so horrible and horrible would
come home when I lift up the book cover.
Hello mister marriage.
And so we find it,
I finally got him to go to a therapist.
Thank goodness,
aren't you great therapists in New York?
Well we kept firing our
therapist and they'll end,
the last therapist fired us and
called us the couple from hell.
So we went to the doors lawyer and we
told our kids we were getting a divorce
and we told all of these and Margaret
therapists were getting a divorce.
So it was really horrible.
And,
and that's when we brought
in zero negativity.
And every night before we go to bed,
we have a calendar now that we
sell to others or give to others.
And did I do anything negative? And
he will point. And I did. I did.
And so we do it next year and the kids
to be checked and we've transformed our
relationship with them.
So yeah, we're if, if we,
if we could do what you any
relationship and turn it around.
So I think it,
I think we need to give the formula
for a great relationship and you will,
and,
and a,
and a winner proceeded with the fact
that the relationship has a process.
It's not,
it is not a destination.
It's a journey is what matters is how
do you take the journey and how you help
each other along the,
we are partners in the project,
not opponents in the project,
in our marriage.
Same thing would happen in any ecosystem.
But here's the kind of of three pieces
that we find indispensable for safe,
thriving relationships where there's
a couple of families, corporations,
congregations of schools you
have to talk without polarizing.
And so the structure that we have
developed and took us about 20 years too,
it may look simple but took about 20 years
to put together the pieces that would
actually work. Of those of
you who are engineers, no,
it doesn't fall in place.
You have to mess with it for awhile.
So the structured conversation that
we demoed, and there's more than that,
two more pieces to that and Helen
just mentioned zero negativity.
What we discovered is you really have
to pay attention to the tendency we have
to do put downs and that's what
we call negativities. Like what?
Where'd you get a stupid idea like that?
Where did that come from?
I can't believe you would say that.
Nobody in their right mind would
ever say anything like that.
You all heard those probably all your
life and none of you have ever engaged in
anything like that. I'm sure the Google
is too enlightening to engage in that.
But that's what most of us do. Those
are called put downs, put downs,
trigger a rupture connection.
The trigger anxiety activates cortisol,
no endorphins there.
So now you go into your defenses.
Then the only thing you can do
is strategic and be tactical.
So if you were just decide,
no put downs and have a culture,
wouldn't it be great if Google had a
culture of zero negativity culture here at
Google? You may have one and
people are working on that.
And then the thing other thing Helen said,
just to emphasize,
it is affirming of the
person you're talking with.
Like thank you very much enjoyed
being with you today. Uh,
I really liked being your partner.
It was great to have this time with you.
I just can't believe I'm
working with somebody. So smart.
Just sentences like that.
And remember you're creating
safety and if you do negative,
you create polarization.
One, it creates safety.
Then you have integration and then you
have creativity that doesn't have a
defense built into it.
Then that experience produces connecting
and that produces full of likeness and
that's what you want and you
can have it with your partner,
you can have it in the workplace,
you can have it with anybody with whom
you have a reliably safe and predictable
relationship through a
conversational process.
So that's all I in any,
any other questions?
I know we have look at
go few more minutes.
Did you want to add anything to add?
Just
a quick question question you have.
I wrote about
um, different attachment styles and you
have like the anxious and the avoidant.
I'm curious if you have like an
anxious and avoidant, right? Um,
and the first question is,
is now a good time to talk?
And the person keeps saying,
no, it's never a good time.
There's too much going on.
And obviously the anxious attachments,
I was like, I want this resolved now.
Like right now or I can't do
anything else. Um, not that
I speak from experience,
but I'm curious,
I'm curious how,
how do you put this into practice?
Yeah, we've rushed
through the process. Um,
are you available now for an appreciation?
Horrible. Could've said, actually,
I'm in the middle of something,
but if he says that he has to save weird,
he is available.
And then at that time come and get me.
So we,
yes.
So it becomes a culture of
agreement that in this culture,
in this marriage and this
corporate culture, uh, we can,
uh, we can, you can say
no, but if you'll say no,
you have to save when and when you say,
when you have to show up then,
because if you don't,
you reactivate childhood wounds that
are suddenly done by all families,
which is mommy, mommy, Mommy,
let me tell you about the elephant
walking down the street. Mommy says,
I can't do that right now.
Later and later never comes.
So the kid comes back, mommy
and Mama can't talk to you. Now.
Later after a while, the kid will go
away and not, and not asking anymore.
Or The kid will escalate
until mommy has to talk.
And whichever one she responds to,
the kid will habituate as,
that's what you have to do
to get attention around here.
So in order to change it,
they have to be agreements that we are
all partners in the project of being
together. And therefore if now's not
a good time to talk, that's fine.
And tell me what, because I need
predictability. If you're telling me when,
then I'll say fine tomorrow, that's
great. I just know we will talk tomorrow,
tomorrow at 10 o'clock. You show up. I
don't have to come get you. You show up.
So you promise you're
predictable and reliable.
So it has to become a cultural process.
So in couplehood where
there's committed partnership,
we invite people to consciously,
uh,
commit to a conscious relationship and
you can also do that in a non intimate
settings.
Am I answering your question?
Thank you.
Any, is there more? Is there
any last comment or two?
Does that Oh man mean we're done.
Oh, do you know flat? Uh,
I will say then in closing,
we were talking to a room full of
people in Dallas and they said,
uh, uh, who, who are quote,
it's an advocate's committee.
It was our first meeting
of the advocates committee.
And one guy stood up and he said,
you all need to find a really
big tech company because, uh,
and he's in this business world,
but he said tech companies promised
that this technology would strengthen
relationships.
And in many cases the opposite has
happened and you all should partner with a
tech company and get and say,
I'm the tech company that's going to
fulfill the promise that we're going to
really strengthen
relationships in the world.
So if y'all know of a tech company that
might be interested in talking to us,
let us know. I thought that was,
wasn't that a good idea? Yeah.
If we're wanting to get it out.
Isn't that smart?
Okay. So if I got that
you're saying, yeah.
Anyway,
so
could I give you an appreciation?
Okay.
I just want to appreciate what a stunning
appearance you have today and what
clarity of thought in this presentation.
Thank you. I've had a good coach.
You've had a good conversation.
I appreciate working with
you because you make me
Oh look good. And now we're going
to close up with who are we?
We are wonderful.
I am wonderful point.
To the person.
You are wonderful.
And that is the truth.
I the wait.
That changed your neurochemistry the
first five minutes you were in the room,
sir. That puts you into another part
of your brain. And as Helen Fisher fit,
you listened to her.
A whole other set of
neurochemicals started flooding
through your system instead
of cortisol. You had norepinephrine,
all sorts of other goodies.
So thank you for
you are an amazing thank you very much.